how to show but now on television I
follow the Instagram I've been a fan
since day one
ditto me too I mean all about that base
just pretty I mean it was meant for me
so it's like I was like no okay
nobody miss photobomb picture we did
with Michelle Obama it's pretty great
yes but the best part is like Where's
Waldo like find the two classiest yeah
yeah yeah that'd be us when the poblanos
was meant to be there and we were like
whatever we're crashing I yeah I yelled
Obama it's our last chance yeah she's
about to leave so that was it you're
welcome mine if you thank you
I'm always afraid to ask people for
picture oh I just jump on it oh my god
we didn't have that boy just we're in
the right place at the right time yeah
but you also have something in common
with me I love having family around you
travel with your family right they're
here today they are in the front row my
family comes to work with me too a lot
my like my whole family sometimes my
husband loves it that's sarcasm yeah
he's always like cool everyone's coming
for a we everyone cool yeah I love it
though I'd love to be surrounded me -
you see him we're like in the green room
chillin but you were the only one that
let them come out I wanted them to cut
cuz your new big day I'm a fan of your
dad I wish I had a dad like him he's so
cool like I am NOT good for all of that
I got real lucky you did I want you to
know to be so grateful for that yeah I
heard he took over your social media
he's really supportive on that it's just
really good at it but and he's really
brave he like he posts all the time to
support me one time he posted my outfit
right before a big show and it was
supposed to be a big reveal but he
posted it with safety pins and all and
we were like
I'm excited for the show and I was like
oh it's cute I love you Gary he's a
superstar by God I love you so now you
perform with Meghan right I've heard
she's not the only one Grace in the
stage do you have a song or something
that yes comes out on my last album I
wrote a mom song I let you mom and I
wrote a dad song because you can't do
one without the other so is it dance
like your daddy and so every time I
perform this song I make my father come
onstage and dance with me and it's
pretty hilarious and it really gets the
crowd goes living its best life I love
you you need a show he does yeah that
really liked it subscribe going I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this